I'm Justin Feld. I'm a scout master with Troop 89 in Downersgrove, Illinois.
This edition of the Scout Master podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
Thanks for everything you do, Clark.
And now to you, Scout Master,
Have you heard any good jokes?
One of the ones that I heard recently that I really like is: uh,
why did the nearly blind man fall down the well?
Why
He couldn't see that well.
Oh, that was pretty bad.
Did you tell the dinosaur one?
Oh, no, no, no, tell that one.
What do you call a sleeping dinosaur?
I have no idea,
Clark Green and a dinosaur.
You guys have been getting like boys' life
because all these jokes came straight out of boys' life. I think
What I'm doing is I'm just writing them down and waiting a couple months
so I can mail them in and get the two dollars.
That's what I'm gonna do.
Hey, this is podcast number 340..
Hello and welcome back to the Scout Master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Tell you what? this week we're gonna skip the mailbag, not skip it.
We're just gonna hold it off for a few minutes
And let me get some other business out of the way,
because I wanted to tell you that, um,
we did have a great live chat session this past week,
And Jack Parks, who's a Scout Master in Troop 279
in Peachtree City, Georgia, joined us, as did Edward Steele.
He's the Scout Master of Troop 73 in Bolton, Connecticut.
Christopher Moynihan is from Anacosa, Texas,
where he is the Scout Master for Troop 604..
Arthur Donche joined us from Macarthur Township in New Jersey,
where he's the assistant Scout Master of Troop 55,,
and Ted from Troop 45,, a Scout Master in Glen Allen, Illinois,
also checked in, as well as many of our frequent fliers.
So we had a pretty full slate this past week at the live chat.
Keep an eye on our Facebook feed and our Twitter feed
and come and join us when you see that a live chat is up.
This will usually be Tuesday mornings.
We have a great time on the live chat.
We answer all kinds of questions
and then sometimes we just talk about the weather or stuff
you know.
So come along and join us. It's great fun.
I want to take the time to thank everybody
who's become a Scout Master cgcom
back or since last week.
So thanks to Travis Anderson and Preston Sewell, Cole, Maddox,
Daniel A Dinkin.
All of those folks have become backers since our last podcast.
It's easy to become a backer.
Give us a little financial support.
We have two ways of doing that.
Go to any page at scoutmastercgcom-
We're looking at notes for this podcast
and you can become a backer or you can become a patron,
And I want to say thank you to all of you
who are backers and patrons.
You're the folks that keep things running for us.
Well, if you've been following along
for the past couple of podcasts,
a couple of my old Eagle Scouts
are out hiking the Appalachian Trail.
That's right, they're through hiking the Appalachian Trail.
They started a few weeks ago.
I've been doing my best to keep up with them.
I have another installment,
another conversation that I recorded this past week
with them to play for you.
But before I get to that,
I heard from Bruce Kolkbeck-
And Bruce is an assistant Scout Master, Troop 442
in Salisbury, North Carolina,
And Bruce has been a film-on advisor for many years
And both he and his son- his son in 2012,
and Bruce in 2016,-
have completed through hikes of the Appalachian Trail.
Bruce got in touch with me and shared these reflections.
He says: I don't judge the success of our troop
by how many Eagles we crank out,
but by the number of Scouts that continue
to enjoy their outdoor experiences
and the leadership it builds into their adulthood.
So having two Scouts who are adventurous enough
to take on a commitment as long and tough
as the Appalachian Trail says a lot about your troop
and you as a leader.
It's a gift that keeps on giving. you've done very well,
my friend.
Well. thank you, Bruce.
I appreciate that.
It's been a source of great pride
that those guys are out there doing this
and all the other guys who've been through the troop.
I know that there are some of my other Scouts
who have through hiked the trail
and there are certainly many of them
who keep up their outdoor adventures.
So once again, Bruce, thanks.
Bruce goes on to say
a fellow assistant Scout Master and I
finished our AT through hike last year
over 2000 miles southbound.
So that means they started up in Maine
and they headed to Georgia
In the Northeast. we ran into
college freshman orientation contingents
that were going backpacking
as a way to learn to work together.
Universities like Harvard, Princeton,
Yale and Trinity,
as well as many others, were represented on the trail.
We also saw groups from expensive summer camps
for teens.
We saw outward bound crews
with lots of kids whose parents had paid dearly
for them to get a little dose of an outdoor experience,
And these were all led by paid and trained professionals.
This is something that you and I do as volunteers.
If you've ever wondered how many academically advanced
and ambitious people from Harvard University
it takes to hang a bear bag,
it takes all of them.
I watched chipmunks take apart the food
they left on their picnic table
while they set up their tarp,
And I did shoe the chipmunks away after a while.
Oh,
We saw film on training crews
getting ready for their summer's trek
and we were always impressed
by the quality of skills and leadership
the scouts showed.
The adults who were involved
were really already on vacation
and the scouts were in full charge and on task.
I will say that amongst through hikers,
scouts do have a reputation for being loud
and overcrowding campsites.
It's common to hear through hikers say:
run for your lives at scouts.
Yeah
Well, I know.
Many through hikers told me stories of
scouts arguing over cooking.
Well, that sounds like just about
any camping trip I go on,
And we did see some embarrassing and some,
frankly, downright dangerous behavior
in some of the scouts we encountered.
Their campfires were almost always way too big,
They overcrowded campsites, cut corners
on the trail and often seemed to have
literal no appreciation
for leave no trace principles.
I know people notice what we do as scout units
and we need to be acutely aware of this.
especially in the wilderness,
First impressions are lasting.
I know, boy, there can be some really big
groups on the trail that are loud
and overfilled campsites and
that can be unpleasant for other people
who are out hiking.
So you should really pay attention to that
if you're going on backpacking,
especially someplace as well used
as the Appalachian Trail.
But anyway, Bruce closes with this thought.
He says: if top tier universities
and expensive outdoor training programs
are utilizing the same methods
and providing the same experiences
we provide in scouting,
we must be doing something right.
You know parents need to know about this.
A weekend backpacking trip where
scouts hike for 10 miles
and work together as a patrol or a crew
to accomplish a common goal
is a lesson that is valuable
and that they will carry with them
for the rest of their lives.
There is value here for young people
and it won't cost all that much.
Yeah, certainly not as much
as being a freshman at Harvard University
or going on an outward bound trip.
All those things are great
if you got the money to do it.
but you're getting Bruce's point here right.
Bruce goes on to say
every scout is better for the experience of scouting.
Thanks for listening to my long winded speech.
I rehearsed it for 2,000 miles,
Bruce. thanks so much
Excellent thoughts
and a great perspective from somebody
who has through hiked the trail
and has been as involved and dedicated
to scouting as you've been.
I really do appreciate you being in touch.
Well, as I promised,
I have some bits and pieces of a conversation
I had with our through hiking eagle scouts,
Bucky Kellogg and Wade Bastion.
That's going to take up the remainder of the podcast,
so let's get started. shall we
So gather your hot dogs or your s'mores, if you desire,
and come crowd around your own personal campfire.
So here we are again, folks with Wade Bastion
and Bucky Kellogg.
You would have heard them a podcast or two ago.
They are through hiking the Appalachian Trail.
How are you guys doing?
Oh, fantastic,
Great,
Yeah, feeling very good on this very stormy day
while we're sitting inside
And tell me where you are,
We are in Fontana Dam,
so just before the Great Smoky Mountains.
when the state of North Carolina
Bucky, how many miles in, are you
164.7..
You sure about that?
Yes,
You were hot in February.
It's been pretty warm.
When we climbed up from the Natahala Outdoors Center
I would say it was close to 70.
There was no wind, it was real sunny.
We had just eaten a very large lunch
and we had to do like a seven-mile straight uphill climb.
It was torture.
Oh, so bad.
It's awful.
I ate burgers. two half-pound patties
for a double.
There's stuff on it too.
Yeah, I had a whole list of toppings
and the waitress came over
and I was like just put everything that I can.
So that was like carrying a rock,
like a big 40-pound rock.
Yeah,
Tell me about your knee.
The knee has gotten better.
This thing it happened a bit this past summer
but it really started happening pretty bad on the trail.
I think it's my IT band.
so right along the side of my knee
it gets inflamed and starts hurting after a while,
Mainly on the downhills.
We took time off.
See, we ended up spending about, I think,
like five nights in Hiawasi
just relaxing because of the inflammation.
When we got back on the trail
we were shelter-hopping, doing five, six miles a day,
going real slow, just trying to get
some strength back in there,
And we bumped up to 12, 13-mile days without a problem.
Have you had your knee looked at at all.
I went to the hospital there in Hiawasi
and they just said it was inflammation
and we stopped again when we were in Franklin.
It was a really cool outdoor store called Outdoor 76.
It's a cool shop,
Yeah. it was really neat.
So we stopped there and talked to them for a while
and the guy there that we talked to,
who was like the leg expert,
really put it into perspective.
He essentially compared through hiking
and like the beginning of through hiking
to like spring training and pitchers in baseball,
And sometimes throughout the season
they'll get to like 80,, 90, 100 mile an hour pitches,
But right now in spring training
they're not doing anywhere close to that
because of fear of like hurting their muscles and stuff.
So it's all very slow warm-up.
He really made it clear that the best thing to do
is to slow down.
So we've definitely done that,
especially on the downhill sections.
It's definitely helping.
I really don't feel that much in my knees.
I have an ace bandage that'll wrap my knees in
just for a little bit of compression,
but that's about it.
Do you have hiking sticks?
Yes, Oh yeah,
I started hiking with the trekking poles
while I was a summit steward this past summer
I realized like, oh wow, these really help with my knees
And I've never gone back.
I love my trekking poles.
I know
First time I was up in the Adirondack.
I'm crawling up Mount Marcy just like the way that I do,
And everybody going past me
is like flying along with these trekking poles.
First time I ever saw trekking poles
was on some public television show about hiking.
Somebody had these trekking poles
and they're like: yeah, these are a big deal in Europe,
Everybody loves them and everything.
And I said that is the stupidest. look at the thing.
Because it was no, no, no, no.
You use a good, old-fashioned hiking stick,
You don't use trekking poles.
But if I had had $1,000 going up Mount Marcy
and somebody would part with their trekking poles,
I would have spent $1,000..
Oh yeah,
We actually. we had that conversation today at breakfast.
We were talking about having trekking poles
and using them
And one of the guys we were eating with
was like, oh, I just use sticks I find on the ground.
If one breaks, I pick up another.
It's like, oh, okay, great,
Yeah,
This is the first time I've ever hiked with trekking poles.
I'm not 100% sold,
but I can tell it makes a difference
when I need it to make a difference.
I end up carrying them in one hand a lot
because I don't want to keep that movement.
Just, it starts to annoy me after a while.
It's too much trouble to like collapse them
attached to the pack and then take them off
when you're on downhill.
I don't really want them uphill,
I want them downhill.
Yeah Well, that's where
I mean. I have a lot of trouble downhill
on my knees and stuff.
That's where they really help.
No, I know what you're saying.
They can kind of get in the way.
So you resupplied. how did that happen?
Before the trip started
I was doing a lot of dehydrating
the individual parts for our meals
and then putting them all together
and vacuum sealing them.
We have those in mail drops
that Bucky's mom is sending to us.
We picked up our mail drop
which had seven dinners in it.
We had one leftover dinner
from our last stretch
and we went to the supermarket
to just pick up snacks
and some granola and things.
Have you shed any gear?
Like our third day? I mailed back my camera
and it was so unwieldy
and I couldn't get it that fast,
so I just mailed it back.
I have a Sunto watch
which does a lot of stuff,
but I tend to keep most of that off
because I want to save the battery.
but the one thing it does do-
no matter what
if the pressure really starts dropping-
is it gives me a storm alarm,
which is real nice.
Has it been useful yet?
Not really.
I mean the one thing that I actually,
this past summer
I was talking to one of my co-workers
and I was just mentioning to her,
like you know, this great old man
that I knew once.
he had this great ability
to be able to tell the weather
just from the clouds,
just looking at the clouds.
he could, you know, be a soothsayer
and say exactly what
weather was going to be,
and I thought that was so cool.
and she was like: you know,
you can do that too.
and we looked at the clouds.
the cloud spotters guide-
I think it was
some British dude- wrote it.
it was really funny
and told me all about the clouds,
which led to my first trail name,
which was Cloud Whisperer.
but that is no longer the case.
I just now a guy who stares at the clouds.
oh yeah, we didn't tell the story of Wade's name.
well, tell me the story of Wade's name.
so it started.
we're in camp,
we're just sitting around.
this guy comes in.
he asked us if we knew
what the weather was going to be
and I said I can't remember the last
time I looked at the weather forecast,
because I'm trying this thing
where I look at the clouds
and try and predict
what the weather is going to be like.
from there
he goes: oh, you're some kind of cloud whisperer.
huh, that's your name,
Cloud Whisperer.
so that was my name for about a day
was Cloud Whisperer.
and then the next night
we were in a shelter
so I heard like mice all night
and squirrels or something
like there was just rodents making
noise in the shelter all night.
so we get up,
we pack everything up,
we're sitting there.
Wade finishes stretching
and he like goes to put his shoes on
and he starts laughing
and he comes in
and he's like: oh, hey, check this out.
it just jumps his shoe out
and there was like
a pound and a half of egg corns.
so I started calling him nut shoe.
so he's cloud nut shoe.
yeah,
a squirrel tried to pay him a dowry
and he's a runaway bride.
yeah,
cloud nut shoe.
yeah, just,
I go by just nut shoe for short,
but cloud nut shoe
is the the full thing
that I'll like sign banners and stuff with.
oh okay,
sounds like a girl in 4-H
in in a little town in Indiana
and she has a prize winning Angora Rabbit
and that's what she calls it:
cloud nut shoe.
yeah,
I appreciate you spending some time
again with me. guys,
a lot of people have been interested
in your adventure
in the through hike.
hope you enjoy the smoke.
yeah,
I'm really excited to get moving.
yeah, it'll be a good time.
well, thanks so much for listening to this
340th edition of the scoutmaster podcast.
here's how to keep in touch.
go over to scoutmastercgcom.
we've got about 1500 articles
and all the back editions of the podcast
that you can enjoy
and you can subscribe while you're there
to receive updates to the blog
and the podcast by email.
there are about 16,000 folks
who like scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
we have a parcel of prolific pinners on Pinterest
to pin Pultitudinous pictures.
you can watch us at scoutmastercg on YouTube.
but if none of that makes any sense at all,
if you can't face Facebook
and Twitter makes you better,
you have no interest in Pinterest
and you don't put the? U in YouTube.
don't worry, old timer,
we'll take a good old-fashioned email any time.
that's right.
get in touch with me,
Clark Green at Clark
at scoutmastercgcom.
that's C-L-A-R-K-E
now, if none of that's gonna work for you,
set your secret decoder pin to B2
and commence transmission immediately.
I'm reading you five and ready to copy
now, if you haven't figured it out by now.
the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications
of anyone in particular
other than myself.
I'm not endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts America
or any other scouting organization
for that matter.
it's just me
talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scouts
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun,
here he is our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert,
good luck to you
and good camping.
oh, I thank you, sir.
until next time, everyone.
you.